(bips)
♪ ♪ ♪
- Clôtures de plus de 2 m,
fils de fer barbelé,
caméras de sécurité;
n'entre pas qui veut
chez Solargram Farms.
Le champ compte 10 000 plants de
cannabis et l'espace suffisant
pour en planter 40 000 autres.
Ici, on croit que l'avenir
de l'industrie se déroule
à l'extérieur plutôt que dans
des serres, même s'il n'est pas
possible de produire, l'hiver.
MARC LEBLANC,
président, Solargram Farms
- Moi, je pense qu'on a
une meilleure recette parce
qu'on utilise l'énergie
du soleil, qui est gratuite.
Puis qu'il n'y a aucun effet sur
notre planète, qui devient des
enjeux politiques importants.
- Quand la culture extérieure
à grande échelle est devenue
possible, au printemps 2019,
Marc Leblanc y a vu une occasion
d'affaires. Il a investi
8 millions $ et il estime
économiser plusieurs millions
en cultivant ses plants dehors.
- Moi, ça serait dépasser
un million par mois, au niveau
de coûts d'énergie, juste ici,
si on était à l'intérieur.
Substantiel, énorme. T'sais,
puis il y a quand même un coût
climatique à ce million-là
par mois.
Ça, c'est un nouveau cultivar
qu'on a utilisé cette année.
- Le coût climatique
de l'industrie du cannabis
intéresse le chercheur
David Joly.
DAVID JOLY, prof. Département de
biologie Université de Moncton
- À l'extérieur, évidemment,
bien là, on sauve un petit peu
sur la lumière, c'est sûr.
On profite de la lumière
du soleil. Donc, il y a tous
ces aspects-là qui entrent
en ligne de compte. Donc,
on voit une popularité qui
commence à augmenter dans le but
de rendre le marché
de plus en plus compétitif.
Donc, il y a des gens qui
veulent se tourner un peu
vers la culture extérieure.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Depuis le 31 décembre 2019,
le nombre de titulaires
de licenses autorisés à faire
de la culture extérieure
a presque quintuplé au pays,
passant de 28 à 138,
selon Santé Canada.
ERIKA NARUZAWA, chercheuse en
agronomie Collège commun. INNOV
- C'est quelque chose qui on n'a
pas beaucoup de données fiables;
on a beaucoup des comme...
des sciences grises, disons,
qu'on appelle.
- Une question qui interpelle
aussi Erika Naruzawa.
Les défis de la culture
extérieure sont grands.
C'est pourquoi les scientifiques
comme elle et David Joly
accompagnent les producteurs
pour maximiser les rendements
et limiter l'impact de la météo.
- À l'intérieur, même s'il peut
y avoir des problèmes
de maladies qui affectent
les plantes, donc c'est
évidemment plus facile
de contrôler l'entrée de
ces maladies-là. En milieu
extérieur, bien là, le vent
peut transporter toutes sortes
de champignons ou de bactéries,
donc c'est beaucoup plus facile
d'avoir des problèmes de
maladie. Donc, comme c'est une
culture qui est encore nouvelle,
il y a très peu de maladies
qui sont devenues importantes,
mais ce qu'on pense, c'est
qu'avec l'augmentation en
popularité, l'augmentation
de la quantité de superficies,
finalement, qui sont dédiées
à ces cultures-là, on va voir
des maladies qui vont
prendre de l'ampleur.
- L'objectif, pour rivaliser
avec la culture intérieure :
atteindre un taux de THC
d'au moins 20 %, le seuil
recherché par les consommateurs.
- Mais avec notre équipe,
les cultivars qu'on a,
l'historique qu'on avait avec
les plantes qui connaissent
c'est pour ça qu'on atteint
ces objectifs-là.
- Un taux que Solargram Farms
affirme avoir atteint. Ce n'est
cependant que dans deux mois,
quand le produit sera disponible
sur les tablettes des magasins,
que les acheteurs pourront
juger de sa qualité.
Ici Maude Montembeault,
Radio-Canada, Renauds.